all right welcome to another interview
guys we got Cameron today you know your
least favorite character in the startup
series a top-five character and designer
series yeah I mean thanks for coming you
are definitely the cheapest to get here
also thank you so much you're paying
everyone else all right I don't pay you
[ __ ] all right that's a good start first
things first for people who know who
watch the startup series
well first of all if you don't watch it
you should watch it right now okay there
we go now the thing about Cameron in
startup series is that he's a very you
say a romantic character you know he's
very passionate and something that's a
how are you in real life because like
they only know you Cameron as a
character but they don't know you as you
well they say life imitates art I think
romantics a nice term desperate is
probably a better term for the 3% of
viewers who are women I am single you
know III think at the beginning I didn't
really know what my character was going
to be on the startup series and then I
just came to realize like my acting's
not great but I can be myself I think
your acting is great
unless that's just yourself I am a
lovable dork and real right like when I
was struggling doing push-ups
I was actually struggling play says that
wasn't acting that was reality well I
mean I did tell you to do like a
shit-ton but because we kept we kept
like retaking the same thing I was
exhausted by the end of that and the
heavy breaths those those were real
there's a little bit of reality there's
a little bit of a joke I think it's me
to the extreme so so are you a
programmer or something else in the
startup series you are a programmer I've
written hello world in a few different
languages
thanks thanks I press but no I'm not a
programmer I'm a data scientist okay so
you're a data scientist it's nice so
let's talk about career now and so as a
data scientist first of all now where
did you work
graduated out of UC Berkeley and then I
worked for tinder for a couple of years
and now I am working on an unnamed a
large tech company in the bay Oh sack I
wonder what that
no idea dude I don't know they call it
like head pages yeah can't think of what
that I wonder I wonder what it is
email so wait so tinder was your first
job yeah that is crazy
yeah you know interesting so you might
know a lot about relationships or at
least dating I'm one of those people who
joined tinder because I didn't know how
to take your relationships I feel like
maybe I've learned it's a digital
learning thing oh yeah I learned a lot I
went on how many dates why is my first
year at tinder I went on one date it was
bad well maybe you were just very
selective right no it's like constantly
you get a lot of matches though no no no
I had to put in work to get matches but
yeah the first year was uh those are
roughy and then eventually I started
figuring out what to do and everything
I'm like you know I was going on dates
one or two dates a week by like my
second year at tender just cuz I figure
it out what to do wow that's actually a
long one or two days a week yeah I'm a
first date machine second dates not so
much you never all right one and done
kind of deal okay I'm gonna ask you more
questions about that later because I
want some tips also yeah so you went to
Berkeley and then wait what did your
studies such that you went to data sign
like how do you even know about data
science good question so I was
bioengineer in Berkeley I was pre-med
and then I took organic chemistry and
realized they hated it so you're
supposed to be a doctor yeah my parents
thought you were gonna be a dog parents
are both doctors they wanted me to be a
doctor he disowned you yet uh a little
bit they made me take the MCAT when I
got really yeah they didn't make me
study I did not do well on it but they
made me take it because they wanted me
to change my mind they were hoping you
know that the change in their heart of
hearts yeah I'd take to this eight hours
with so much fun man oh I got to do this
more
I got like Caribbean med school scores
like what does that mean so like
MCAT you got to get like ten points
above the average to get into like a
good US med school uh-huh I got four
points above the average which is like
you can get into a Caribbean med school
this is where like people go if they
don't get
to any of us med schools I go hang out
there 14 years I did pre-med I graduated
pre-med but I knew at that point I
didn't want to do do bio anymore I want
to do some mixture of like stats and
psychology so I applied to PhDs in game
theory
mm-hm and I hadn't taken a single econ
class in my life and so I got rejected
from every single PhD that I applied to
and so I I panicked a bit I applied to
115 jobs out of undergrad and then it
was a mixture of like analytics product
management and then UX research and the
analytics once were the only ones that
really called me back because I had the
math background for it so then I went
into analytics attender you were doing
biomedical engineering yeah and and
there were a lot of math and that I
guess yeah I mean it's like a lot of
engineering classes I had like I like
stats so I did a lot of stats class I
and everything kinda like the bio II in
itself was enough to handle any of the
math that you do as a data scientist
yeah that makes sense yeah cuz I was
wondering like with that degree do they
even like look at you because I feel
like they would filter like I guess not
on my team there's a lot of people who
are like by own physics PhD is like when
I write yeah my data science tamson
there's like a lot of people that came
from like a bio and an engineering
background actually there's more who do
that then come from like a stats
background or a math background and then
when you start your first shot at tinder
did you enjoy it or did you not like why
did you switch I liked it but I was
working on in Texas Texas is one of
those places where like if you have a
family it's nice it's great place to
have like golden retriever two kids
white picket fence right but like as a
22 year old you can only eat so much
barbecue and like I was putting on
weight and I don't really have any
friends out there because I've never
lived out there it always lived in
California and so like it just it was
boring so I tried to move back to the
day and what I did I was recruited you
could get really huge houses there
is right she yeah did you get a nice
house like $200,000 or so and we should
all move to Texas get four and rises up
again I mean a lot of companies are
going to Austin at this point okay why I
guess the price is gonna rise that yeah
it's going to it sucks
so did you study for your data science
interviews I spent a week learning
sequel just like you I did I think
w3schools
I just picked it up super quickly also
learned a lot from brilliant org it's
Bri not sponsored is now we're not gonna
give them free sponsorship sorry about
that yeah to get a data science
interview you need sequel and then you
need like either R or Python and
honestly that's about it okay like when
I interviewed for analyst positions like
on the other end does the interviewer I
kept on seeing resumes that were just
like packed with every programming
language possible and like I usually
trash them cause lately well the reality
is that like all these people have the
exact same resume like it's literally
templated and not like not the exact
same word for word but like objectively
the same and then when I see a hundred
of those I don't know which of the
hundred depict so I don't pick any of
them
the reason being like I look for people
who have some distinct interests in the
field and that gives me a better signal
like there's a reason they're applying
this job instead of just spamming their
resume out to everywhere it sounds a
little bit like dating it does sound a
little bit like because I you know my
profile is generic so I can apply it the
most because you do you have a can't
pickup line
no I don't actually I just say hey you
say hey and that works
no okay Acula okay yeah you're looking I
mean that's the thing like if there are
girls I don't really care about then I
say hey because if they say hey back and
they talk to me they must really like me
mm-hmm so I'd be down if someone's reads
like so really into me right but if it's
someone that I think like wow she's so
hot or like oh she's so interesting
then I'll take more like I'll take the
time to like look at a profile which I
think of a funny line and then
do it how many responses do you get when
you say hey Lana telling us yeah oh yeah
right yeah one out of ten that's
actually like pretty good really that's
actually not bad well I mean I don't get
along matches either right so yeah
you're saying as if you have ten matches
dude you know small numbers I have a
response on five matches so what did you
learn about dating when you worked at
tinder man so much um I'm gonna try not
talking about the math part first cuz
like I think there's a lot of cool math
and there's a lot of like optimization
but like what I learned more about was
kind of the mindset of dating and by
that I mean like you can really go into
dating with two different mindsets well
first off you could just not date and I
know a lot of people that do that and
like they're happy doing that but they
also want to get married and they just
don't know when that's going to switch
that little switch is gonna flip and
they're gonna be like wait I need to
start dating so a lot people kind of
push it off that's one like failed
mindset but the one that that a lot of
people have is that like the first dates
an interview and that like you're trying
to gauge them you're trying to be
impressed by them and you're also trying
to impress them and it makes it really
stressful and I was guilty of this when
I started dating to where I was like oh
god I have to be like I'm my best form I
got to put on my nicest shirt I got it
like you know gel up my hair and all
kind of stuff I mean what Jellico it
looks really bad by the way but I
eventually realize alee dating is about
the process like the process itself is
the part that's meant to be enjoyable
just meeting people doing things that
you want to do anyway I started going on
like fun dates instead of just getting
dinner every single time so like I'd
start doing like mini golf or even like
laser tag like these childish but like
fun dates like hiking all kind of stuff
just like you enjoy the experience and
like having someone there with you makes
it that much better it's no longer
contingent on that person one of things
I've learned a tinder from like all the
research and interviews idea is that
like the people who go into that mindset
are just so much happier with the
process and they're a lot more
successful too
interesting like I think fundamentally
I'm kind of the same like I just want to
have fun and stuff like that you know
I'm not trying to impress them on the
song interview but the process is
totally different
also it versus you so you're trying to
have like a fun day you know like laser
tag and stuff like that
I always do the same date what's your
date
well oh [ __ ] what's your move I don't
know if I can say this because there's
[ __ ] okay oh my god so everyone shits
on my on my move because it's it is the
[ __ ] site I bring them to the unnamed
company okay where are we working so I
bring them there everyone says like
that's what Bella's saying it's like
it's not a good day or whatever but for
me it's because I want a little risk
date right because I don't even know if
I'm gonna like you or not
so why am I gonna invest so much time
and money into you and then because I
bring them to campus it's free aren't
you nervous about like co-workers seeing
you like going on like a random date and
then like the cafeteria though oh no I
don't care like whoa like I mean it
isn't it cool for me am i old
yeah the date I'm always like so
paranoid that like people will start
like whispering and muttering about her
whenever like one of my nightmares that
I run into a co-worker while on a date
or something yeah I want them to talk
about it I want them to be like oh wow
John was on the day yay kind of thing
but anyway so the thing is even before I
went to unnamed large company my dates
would be always the same as in like yeah
it's dinner at the same place dessert at
the same place like it's it's like
rehearsed kind of do you have rehearsed
conversations to okay rehearse
conversations no but rehearse topics yes
yeah because because it always it
naturally goes into those topics right
but but the thing is I'm not trying to
like show that I'm really cool or does
like an interview or I want to get to
know what I wanna say I don't want to
try to get to know them but not in a
good way because because I think okay
honestly I think my second date ratios
are pretty is pretty good and because
like I just try to entertain them for
the first day you know like my best
jokes or whatever
I just have fun of them so I kind of
want to break the ice as soon as
possible and that's how I do it yeah I
learned nothing about them and they
usually learn nothing about me either
but we just talk about really random
stuff that's funny or fun I think the
reason why it goes to the second date so
often is because one for once they don't
feel like that awkward small talk are
trying to force yourself to learn about
the other person because we didn't learn
about each other you know it was purely
just fun right well that's how I enjoy
my first days at least and this is one
of the things that I mean I learned is
that you know a first date you you check
off the boxes for the other person
somewhat so like you don't necessarily
ask them about their deepest personal
secrets but like you find out if they're
compatible religion you ask about
politics these things that are actually
considered taboo like ensuring that
compatibility like saves you a lot of
time especially like in the bay like
weird politics is such a big deal here
if I'm dating a girl and like she's not
cool with the fact that I'm libertarian
and not liberal which a lot of girls
here like aren't like you know I'm not
I'm not crazy about it but like if she's
crazy about it ends right there um a lot
of people will assume that getting to
the second date is like a positive step
I think a lot of times avoiding the
second date can be a positive step in
that like you're getting that signal
fast enough that like you figure out
whether or not you actually have
interest in this person and that's not
me rationalizing cuz I never go on but
like III think you know in general
whenever I've gone past the second date
has been with someone that I've actually
been very compatible with and I feel
like that's been more valuable to me
than kind of wasting my time on second
and third dates with people I'm not
actually interested in I think that
makes a lot of sense because ya know
most of the times like even if I go to
seven dates their dates and only like
the girl that much right and I think
that's the problem because I wasn't
optimizing for a lay-oh finding someone
that's compatible it was me just maybe
just like an ego thing try and be like
oh yeah I got to the second day
kind of thing and it was a lot less
about us but more about me kind of a
thing I think it's a really easy to set
checkpoints like even everyone does this
on tinder - right you compare how many
matches you have read other people part
of its because the process is gamified
and so like it's really easy to tie
things to it and calculate exactly how
you're doing and track all that it's
addictive you know gets people to keep
on using yeah for a potential girlfriend
that there are certain checkboxes right
but these checkboxes don't really mean
anything once I start talking them and I
just really enjoy myself with them I
always end up in the stage where it's
like oh I really enjoyed this person but
she doesn't have these certain
checkboxes you know it's a little bit
shallow but for a girlfriend or at least
like or like a wife you know I want her
to make you know at least a decent mom
my college educated stuff like that but
sometimes I meet girls who are like
non-college educated even or even they
do something that I really don't care
about but I have a lot of fun with them
so I continue like let's try to help
them yeah but it always has to end hang
out yeah I go on they hurt them a lot
right yeah cuz I do enjoy their company
but then once it comes to like something
more serious as I thought it has to end
and I feel like I've wasted a lot of my
time because of that mmm that's kinda
like that whole equalist thing you're
like crying yourself wiping away the
tears with your money take a look piece
of meat because you know dating is kind
of like a funnel right like you have to
get matched first and then you have to
get whatever that how do you optimize
the top of the funnel which is through
dating apps yeah
99% of your profile is your photos right
and everyone says that bio matters bio
it doesn't matter anyway I'm gonna call
out one of my favorite books which is
data quiz Oh mom it's written by
Christian rudder he's the former CEO of
OkCupid a really smart guy really fun
guy and he did a lot of analytics so
he'd actually eventually step down as
CEO do 50% CEO and then 50% just writing
the blog and doing analytics okay cute
because that's what he really loved too
and one of his posts is about how they
tried to have OkCupid like users rate
other users based on their looks and
based on their personality if you had
really good looks
you also got rated really high in
personality even if you had a blank bio
this one girl who is like it's like a
black and white model photo of her with
like a log or something here you can you
can just edit it and write here
something like that her like average
personality rate he was like a 4.5 out
of 5 or something just because she was
that hot it really is your photos that
matter
um I don't think many people are
naturally ugly I think a lot of people
just don't feel comfortable with having
photos taken of them like myself 100
percent included there so when I started
tinder I had a lot of like blurry photos
bad lighting
I know group photos that kind of stuff
cuz I don't like being in front of a
camera I'm one of those people were like
my natural reaction to seeing a camera
is to do like a stupid face kind of
thing it's just I did that all as even
as a kid I fixed a lot of that's like I
wonder how to smile normally I kind of
upgraded my photos a bit to be more of
if you're going to use like the timer or
you could take selfies with a good
camera
I have friends so y'all friends oh oh I
don't think any of my photos are selfies
god I hope they aren't you know my
profile picture like the black-and-white
one yeah I said most of them that's
that's a timer right yes so what I mean
it is a selfie as and I took it but yeah
it's a timer how many takes did you have
to do for that one I don't know like
20-something thirty some item you are
dedicated of faces silly except one
that's like okay and then when I put on
like Facebook people secretly tell me
like oh by the way it's not a good photo
[ __ ] it's like you don't know
what's a good photo of yourself and not
always right there is one like secret
trick that does actually work which is
including dogs in your profile and like
it's one of those stereotypical things
where people think it doesn't matter
that much but it boosts your rights
white grape I like a huge margin just
having a dog in your profile even if
it's not your dog yeah I did have my dog
in my father
I have a dog and I had a cuter dog in my
photos instead my dogs no longer a puppy
side to find this other puppy and put in
my gonna be I don't love you absolutely
love my dog I'm sorry static very good
boy so I guess for the remaining of the
time I'll just talk about like you as a
person because you know people want to
get to know you I think at least like
the people on disk you all like five
people who are interested yeah bring you
10 views on this bad boy so what do you
do for fun so I was a competitive gamer
in college oh [ __ ]
League of Legends [ __ ] no idea yeah I
never told you about this how much I
played um I've been playing since season
one I got up to like high master was
really close to Challenger back in the
day so I used to play a lot just end up
on like pro streams just to get
recognized that was like a big motivator
for me I still play now but not really
as good but like just the fact that
people knew my name was like so
satisfying to me even if they didn't
think I was a good player for my rating
yeah I was known for being one of the
worst players I was a rainy day piece
out yeah I know what that means
no police so oh yeah did you know me too
oh [ __ ] it was fun it was a time sink um
so I still play that I do Bar trivia bar
chip oh yeah yeah I was a quiz bowl nerd
in high school wait so is it trivia for
anything or just shows or it's a lot of
pop culture a lot of pop culture I'm a
sports buff mostly so I guess I do i do
fantasy football and and I watch a lot
of hockey I'll go to maybe a five or six
sharks games a year be getting into a
couple weird things recently I'm game
not weird but like weird for me been
getting into meditation oh that's good
that's been I tried getting into it yeah
I was okay for a while but then I
suddenly started and never came back
yeah I think I should try to come back
to it wait but why do you like
meditating I I recognize that it's like
getting stressed just oh and so like it
was one of those things where I was like
I need to control this do use headspace
yeah you said space that's a she now
what love are you bro I mean I've only
been
now for like a few weeks I'm yeah yeah
amateur hour here yeah but it's been
helping so far I think it's important to
get that like I'm going to make a bold
statement I don't know if it's true I
think anxiety and depression are pretty
common in the Bay Area due to the amount
of stress that work puts on you here
like I definitely felt more stressed
here than I did when I was living out in
Texas and I think that's true for like a
lot of other people that's been one
thing the other one I'm starting to
learn is Mandarin so I can hit on
Chinese co-workers I'm starting to
wearing like basic sentences understand
the tones that kind of stuff cool it's
one of the things where I feel like it's
actually useful to know here given that
like so many of my co-workers are like
native Mandarin speakers and whenever
I've learned a language in the past you
hit that point where you start like
speaking it with people and then like I
didn't have anyone to speak anything
with here I don't think that's gonna be
a problem
yeah so lots of co-workers yeah cool all
right well that's about it thank you so
much for the interview thank you thank
you yeah we grab all about dating and
you know hopefully a lot of my viewers
are gonna get some tips and tricks and
then they won't watch my videos anymore
because they have something better to do
if you hit up the discord I will give
out some profile critiques to y'all you
know emotion yeah it takes me like 30
seconds both to critique a profile and
also in bed so it'll be quick all right
cool cool so yeah so before and then
just want say that this video is
sponsored by expressvpn protect your
private data better than cameron
protects his virginity with expressvpn I
use expressvpn when shopping or working
on sensitive stuff abroad or in public
cafes in those cafes their networks are
unsecured so it leaves user at great
risk for example a man-in-the-middle
attack can occur when someone intercepts
your data requests so allows them to
eavesdrop and exploit real-time
transactions and conversations allowing
them to steal your personal information
expressvpn lets you use the internet
without being tracked keeping your
emails downloads and search histories
private every time you use the internet
without expressvpn you're putting your
sensitive data at risk expressvpn cost
less than seven dollars a month and run
seamlessly in the background of your
computer phone or tablet
take back your internet private
see today and see how you can get three
months free by going to expressvpn calm
slash coma that is exp ress VP and calm
/j oma for three months free with a
one-year package so yeah visit
expressvpn dot-com / coma to learn more